i've worn three outfits today and i
couldn't remember which was which but
yeah this is rodate i mean
it's so beautiful fabulous um i have to
ask you because we were just talking the
wonderful chris pine who's going behind
you right now um he was just like i
loved making this movie because
you're so amazing and because it's like
a sexy hot great movie it really is it's
i think it's like harking back to a time
of old when romance was
something that we all wanted to
think about and
get excited about and
it's like an old movie like casablanca
or you know that film noir but it's got
that modern edge obviously because
when i saw the trailer i was like this
is the movie i wish we made more of
which is
yeah yeah yeah i agree i i i love it i
mean god the fact that the love story is
as important
as all of the
you know cia drama and the fact that
there's a woman in the middle of it all
a woman in the middle of this cia drama
you know literally commanding the
narrative it's not something that
i've certainly done that much of and
doing it with chris he's the loveliest
guy oh my god but in terms of being a
human rights activist i was i was glad
to see that the film was dealing so
effectively and sensitively with issues
that we deal with in the world in terms
of terrorism and
um and what i particularly admired about
yanus
our director's work was how he allowed
us to speak to real representatives from
the cia so we had a consultant from the
cia who advised us throughout the movie
i spent a number of hours talking to her
she was african-american
and had worked in the cia for a number
of years really a whole career
and i wanted to represent her
and other women like her
who have taken up positions in the cia
against all odds
um and i feel when i've seen the movie
and i think that we achieved a lot we
really really did and we meant it and we
cared but at the end of the day it's a
movie it's entertainment it's
it's a romantic thriller
and
i'm also extremely proud of how we
managed to you know make make that love
story so authentic really you really
feel that the heart of the story last
question i did hear that you said that
you were a little nervous to work with
him because he's so handsome
well
no yeah i was a bit i just you know oh
god
we had a really intense scene right in
the middle of the movie it was
incredibly important and
required nudity and so on and i just
caught a glimpse of chris
at one point you know like we're getting
costumes and hair and makeup and i'm
like oh no no no no
no
and so yeah i had a little i i summoned
the uh the dp actually and said is this
gonna be okay of course it is of course
girls we get insecure right and i you
know my baby he's seven now but still
still people okay
um
and yeah he's such a sweetie and
it was all handled so beautifully too uh
intimate seems so amazingly handled
because we had an intimacy coordinator
so everyone knew what was doing what was
happening
what was going where and
well that's important
yeah it is isn't it what's going where
is important and consent
listen
it was actually all about consent
that's why we have the intimacy
coordinator so everyone can sense every
detail of what's happening
everyone's in agreement everyone
witnesses everybody and then we go to
work
you